pour moi on n'a pas besoin d'être
féministe pour défendre les droits des
femmes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est très dur d'être une
femme célibataire en maroc parce que sa
place dans l'entreprise dans l'économie
elle se réduit de jour en jour de moins
en moins de femmes qui travaillent dans
la politique
on voyait il ya 15 20 ans des femmes
ministres des postes importants
aujourd'hui et sont relégués tout au
bout de la table au mieux secrétaire
d'état il ya une ministre dans tout
gouvernement et je trouve qu'en matière
de libertés individuelles de droits
civiques fondamentaux les grands combats
qu aurait dû mener certaines femmes
n'ont pas été menées parce que souvent
la femme peut aussi être la pire ennemie
de la femme
on l'a vu en 2015 par exemple quand le
conseil national des droits de l'homme a
posé au maroc la question de l'égalité
dans l'héritage en tête de manif dans
les cortèges
c'était des femmes qui manifestaient
contre leurs propres droits et on le
voit d'ailleurs dans le film ça peut
être complètement surréaliste à croire
et pourtant ces femmes sont comme lié
par des chaînes il ya une forme de
tutelle qu'elle n'arrive pas à briser à
cause de l'ignorance à cause de
l'éducation pour plein de raisons
et pourtant que ces femmes là qui vont
éduquer aussi les hommes de demain
puisque ce sont leurs enfants et c'est
pour ça que c'est comment dire très
important d'avoir aussi des exemples de
femmes qui mènent ces combats au grand
jour comme salima dans le film parce que
mener ces combats au grand jour ces
êtres inspirante
c'est que une gamine des quartiers
populaires des faubourgs de casablanca
se disent mais bon sang mais je veux
être comme lcl à qui j'ai envie de
ressembler cl mon modèle et moi je crois
beaucoup à cette idée de d'exemplarité
le mouvement mis tout n'a pas encore
véritablement atteint le maroc parce
qu'il ya des femmes qui ont témoigné
dans les journaux marocains de scènes de
harcèlement qu'elles ont subies mais
sans véritablement hawks aille plus loin
à part récemment où il ya un journaliste
qui a été accusé de harcèlement et cette
fois ci de manière totalement ouverte et
ça a été la première fois
il ya un article qui a été aboli ou qui
disait que un violeur peut au cas où la
victime l'acceptent épouser la femme
qu'il aurait violée
bon alors c'était une espèce de truc
complètement dingue
l'aca a été abolie donc il ya des
avancées si vous voulez après quand je
regarde par exemple cette loi contre le
harcèlement
je me dis c'est bien mais elle va pas
assez loin le viol conjugal par exemple
qui est représente le cas le plus le
plus répandu de violences faites aux
femmes
il est même pas évoqué dans ses toits je
crois qu'il faut rien lâcher parce que
il y a aujourd'hui un clivage très très
fort entre deux schémas de société alors
ya un schéma de société qui veut nous
ramener en arrière et mettre des
interdits des tabous à chaque coin de
rue nous contraindre nous restreindre et
puis il ya aussi des gens qui ont envie
de se projeter vers l'avant et moi j'ai
envie de croire que même si on est
minoritaire dans ce cas là bas les
grands changements dans l'histoire de
l'humanité ils ont été menées par des
minorités donc j'ai envie d'avoir de
l'espoir